السودانيه مشتعله في انتظار ما ستسفر عنه
الجهود الراميه في اخمادها فلازمه دخلت
يومها الرابع والعشرين دون ان يصل طرف
الصراع الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
الى اتفاق ولو مؤقت لوقف اطلاق النار غياب
ارضيه للتفاهم ترك الوضع على حاله لتتجدد
الاشتباكات وتواصل حصد الضحايا في اخر
الاحصاء لعدد الضحايا كشفت منظمه الصحه
العالميه ان عدد القتل جراء الاشتباكات في
السودان وصل الى 604 قتله من بينهم مدنيون
كما ان القتال ادى الى اصابه ما يزيد عن
5100 شخص نقلا عن المنظمات نفسها
وفاتوره الحروب لا تقتصر على الضحايا فحسب
بل تشمل النازحين ايضا فنقلا عن المنظمه
الدوليه للهجره التابعه للامم المتحده فان
المعارك المتواصله في السودان تسببت في
نزوح ما يقرب من 700 الف شخص لحد الان
والحصيله مرشحه من دون شك الى الارتفاع
والى جانب المعارك المتواصله على ارض
القتال تتواصل معركه تبادل الالتهابات وفي
جنيدها اتهام الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم
السريع بالاستمرار باعمال نهب البنوك
والمحلات التجاريه وسرقه ممتلكات
المواطنين
عمليه النهب والسرقه باتت عنوانا رئيسيا
للازمه في السودان وهو ما تطرقت اليه
منظمات دوليه فقد ادانت منظمه الامم
المتحده نهب مجمع رئيسي لبرنامج الاغذيه
العالمي في العاصمه الخرطوم مؤكده تاثر
وكالات الامم المتحده وجميع شركائها في
المجال الانساني باعمال النهب في السودان
ودحت المنظمه الامميه الى ضروره حمايه
واحترام العاملين في المرافق الانسانيه
بما في ذلك المستشفيات دون ان تتهم اي طرف
محدد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات